jawohl die aussage dass der ungeimpften
nicht selbst nur sich selbst gefällt dir
doch nie gestimmt
die hat in der tat so nicht findet das
kann man sagen und das ist ja das was
ich persönlich auch als unangenehm
empfinde wenn jemand ungeimpft ist und
er sagt ich steckte mich nicht anderen
ist das seien wir aber wir wissen dass
er andere damit gefährdet man hat aber
schon den eindruck dass in der fdp
solche ja wissenschafts leugnung oder
unkenntnis von wissenschaftlichen fakten
sehr verbreitet ist also auch in den
letzten wochen und monaten noch bis hin
in die vierte welle hinein immer wieder
solche statements kamen opfern herrn
buschmann von herrn dörfern herrn
lindner die eben solche dinge
behaupteten wie eine ungeimpfte
werden höchstens sich selber man braucht
keinen lockdown mehr unser
gesundheitssystem wird nicht belastet
also immer wieder diese steilen thesen
die dann in der bevölkerung auch dazu
führen dass die menschen mit ar schlimm
sie das kaum mit international inc also
die aussage wir brauchen keinen lockdown
zu einem zeitpunkt die muss politisch
weiter möglich bleiben also ob wir einen
doktor machen oder nicht entscheidet die
politik und da kann die fdp auch sagen
ich muss gar nicht dieser meinung seien
wir brauchen jetzt keinen lockdown da
könnte ich nicht sagen das ist
unwissenschaftlich nein das geht
natürlich ist nicht das habe ich so auch
nicht alle in einen sack gesteckt es
ging ja darum zu sagen es sind keine
massnahmen notwendig war in unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet würde
das war ja die aussage zu einer zeit wo
schon sehr klar war dass unser
gesundheitssystem bei der info
tatsächlich wirklich wieder an den rand
der belastende das ist nicht schlimm
dass die fdp die liberalen an gang hatte
ich mal dafür gibt es auch eine liberale
mehrheit
das ist völlig in ordnung sich
schwieriger finde ist dass die fdp jetzt
in der regierung ist und prinzipiell
haben die führenden leute der fdp ja den
weg zur impfpflicht wollen die den mit
gehen also christian lindner sagte er
tritt der ideen er aber er hat dafür in
seiner fraktion keine mehrheit und er
holt sich die mehrheit nicht und dadurch
haben wir dieses seltsame dinge dass wir
eine regierung haben wo heute der
regierungschefs in der
regierungsbefragung vors parlament tritt
und auf die frage was ist mit der
impfpflicht sagt dazu sage ich nichts
als regierung dazu sage ich nur was als
abgeordneter und privatmann und das ist
ein problem über eine regierung muss in
solchen fragen eine linie haben über
welche linien können wir uns dann
anschließend unterhalten aber die müssen
eine linie haben stellen wir uns vor
1999 rot grüne regierung joschka fischer
habe ich sowohl einsatz kosovo-einsatz
joschka fischer dafür gekämpft dass
dieses auslandseinsatz gibt stellen wir
uns vor ihrer spa fischer hätte gesagt
also als außenminister habe ich keine
meinung aber als abgeordneter bin ich
dafür das geht nicht und da müsst die
fdp und linda und auch scholz da muss
olaf scholz jetzt sagen was ist der plan
der regierung für die impfpflicht und
dann kann nicht sagen das sind als
minister vergessen der
gesundheitsminister sagte er ebenfalls
der weg aus der pandemie ja das ist ja
na klar wir gut aber was ist denn
eigentlich wollte nur sagen das ist ja
eine regierung besteht ja auch aus
fachleuten und ich teile übrigens ihre
einschätzung dass es eine gewisse
irritation ist wenn ein bundeskanzler
sozusagen keine explizit keine meinung
äußert wenn ich die letzten vier wochen
nehme dann wurde die war die
argumentation es kommen eben weil es
keine einheitliche meinung dazu gibt ja
impfen einimpfen oder unterschiedlichen
variationen aus dem parlament heraus ist
gruppenanträge geben über die wird
abgestimmt das ist übrigens legitim ist
übrigens bei diskussionen sie auch
ethisch geführt werden und das ist eine
das ist
wirklich ein erlebnis für mich jetzt
schon so alexander
das argument dass herr lauda sie was sie
können also das war die argumentation
vor einigen wochen es wird
gruppenanträge geben die kommen übrigens
auch drei vier unterschiedliche hinter
dem verbergen sich übrigens nicht nur
die fdp die grünen die spd
möglicherweise die cdu sondern an jedem
gruppenantrag wird ein farbenspiel sich
abspielen wenn ich mal von dem ganz
rechten und linken verschiedene ideen
sozusagen impfpflicht war 60-jährigen es
gibt ja gibt ja nicht viele
möglichkeiten die möglichkeit gegen
impfpflicht so den wolfgang kubicki ist
es gibt die möglichkeit ich möchte eine
impfpflicht auf teufel komm raus dann
gibt es aber auch so ich meine ist
dürfte sie fragen ab 60 ist sinnlos oder
finde ich übrigens aber noch steigen
weil die meisten über 60 der relativ
hohe importe haben weil sein soll kann
die region bereitet doch gerade was über
50 fordern ich ja gut
also situation unterstützt mich glauben
und gibt kollegen die sagen 60 ist so
später über 50 dann kann man sagen ab 18
also alle erwachsenen sungen dann nehmen
wir drei oder vier anträge ich weiß
nicht wie viele kommen und die werden
abgestimmt und die mehrheit ist dann das
was umgesetzt
darüber kann man natürlich streiten ob
das in der jetzigen phase sinnstiftend
ist also so wird es kommt oder ob man
auf der anderen seite von der regierung
sozusagen ein angebot erweitert sich
doch wie kommt deswegen nicht weil es
eben innerhalb der regierung und
innerhalb der fraktionen ganz
unterschiedliche meinungen geben
verstehen auch mal ich hab ja auch
kontakt zu ihrer verteidigt weiß auch
dass bei der cdu csu da es sehr
unterschiedliche positionen gibt weil
die antwort ist es nicht so einfach also
was ich finde das geht so wirklich nicht
also wir haben doch schon mal über eine
impfpflicht abgestimmt impfpflicht für
masern ist erst drei jahre hören sie
nicht vergleich niemand kam um berlin
sie nicht vergleichen alexander an das
wissen darüber geht um kinder geht sowas
hab ja schon viele magische moment nein
nein jetzt habe ich auch seien daher
also das argument eine frage wäre so
wichtig dass sie eine
gewissensentscheidung ist es ist schon
mal ganz falsch und kriegseinsatz ist
auch wichtig und jede entscheidung
noch immer gibt es keinen fraktionszwang
können sie bei der abstimmung sehen also
als schröder fischer in den kosovo
gegangen sind haben die großen wert
darauf gelegt dass die grünen mit
stimmen trotz ihrer pazifistischen
hintergrund und auch wenn die stimme von
der union kam haben schröder fischer
gezeigt das ist die entscheidende frage
da haben wir eine mehrheit als koalition
das nennt man kanzlermehrheit und jetzt
ist corona die entscheidende frage und
deshalb ist kubicki sagt gestern das ist
wie mit der sterbehilfe sterbehilfe ist
doch ein phänomen für wenige hundert
leute und soll das hoffentlich auch
bleiben wir reden doch etwas der
gesundheitsminister sagt der weg aus der
pandemie ist das impfen und die
regierung sagt dazu können wir aber
leider keinen vorschlag machen das geht
nicht da reißt auch etwas ein von
staatsverständnis was nicht gesund daran
dass ja noch zwei verschiedene sachen
der weg aus der pandemie ist das impfen
so viel ist sicher aber ob der weg aus
der pandemie die impfpflicht ist
nicht eben das impfen tatsächlich
befördern wird insofern und es ist
einfach ein großer eine frage mit
wirklich großen ethischen potenzial
großem spalterischen potenzial von daher
kann ich dem folgen dass man sagt dies
ist eine medizin ethische frage und beim
medizin ethischen fragen ist es häufig
so gewesen dass man genau mit solchen
gruppen an karl josef laumann bild schon
die ganze zeit und wartet geduldig bitte
also es ist ja so dass wir ein bisschen
altmodisch aufgestellt sein wir haben
ein bundeskanzler der sagt er will
lebenslicht er als person mit
lebenslicht und ich bin schon der
meinung da ist ein bundeskanzler für das
was er will eine eigenständige mehrheit
hatten muss das heißt also die position
für position das macht ein altmodisches
virus verständnis sagen aber war aber
bislang eigentlich immer ein regler muss
bundesrepublik ein regierungschef für
das was er will und dafür gibt es
koalitionsfraktionen das stimmt also ist
nicht die koalitionsfraktionen haben
sich gleich bestellen auch meine
fraktion im landtag von
nordrhein-westfalen dass unser
ministerpräsident über eine mehrheit im
landtag verfügt so funktioniert so
verstehe ich politik und da muss man es
erst einmal in einer koalition sind die
hand klären
aber wenn ein parlament natürlich sagt
wir machen das parlament steht über
alles das muss jetzt auch mal wieder
sagen dafür bin ich sehr gerne in mein
leben kommentare gewesen das verstehe
ich auch aber muss schon sagen es ist ja
schon in der jetzigen ab so dass man
wahrscheinlich auch den weg über die
gruppenanträge deswegen gemacht weil man
sich nicht sicher ist dass man in dieser
frage ein ganzer hang ist natürlich
steht das ist doch so und deswegen das
müsse sich jetzt schon dass die fdp oder
dirigierten die ampel sich schon von
einem cdu jetzt andere dass man sagt wir
glauben dass ihr das so macht weil ihr
keine eigenständige mehrheit in dieser
frage auch den sonst so und das muss man
dann auch so sagen dürfen und dann
müssen sie damit leben dass es in dieser
frage
so ist jetzt will ich noch mal sagen ich
habe ja auch oft gesagt ich will keine
impfpflicht sie müssen eben also wo wir
herkommen ich komm her von einer
situation wo wir ihnen den stoff da war
und die leute schlange standen sich
impfen zu lassen
und damals habe glaube ich alle geglaubt
das wird ein selbstläufer dass wir diese
hohen quoten erreichen weil die menschen
einfach sich befindet damals war noch
noch andere
also andere toten bergen und auf leicht
65 prozent der 80 ich glaube auch 80
prozent würden wir zumindest in vielen
bundesländern erreichen dann haben wir
die situation dass die impfquoten in
deutschland auch sehr unterschiedlich
sind wir haben in den nordischen ländern
eine sehr hohe impfquoten sich ein
stichwort stellenweise handbruch denken
wenn sie am leben hält niedersachsen
denken wie ich bin in nrw unmöglich also
wieso im ersten drittel mit den 75 die
wir ja wie impft haben wenn ich nach
süddeutschland gucken war bayern
ethischen und wieder ein bisschen
schwerer und dass man erst muss man aber
kein wissenschaftler seien finde ich wir
haben doch im november gesehen wo wir
die überlastung wo wir das kleeblatt in
deutschland in gang setzen mussten dass
die über bundesländergrenzen hinaus über
kleber ganze haus verlegen mussten den
intensivstationen da kommt man doch
abzeichnen dass alle bundesländer ein
riesenproblem hatten die anime info.de
in ihrem gang es gab einen zusammenhang
zwischen niedriger
infrastruktur vielleicht ein bisschen an
dass sie lieber das muss man dann auch
wieder dann sehen aber wenn nicht also
nach süddeutschland poker welche
probleme die hatte hatte das auch mit
infekten zu tun und dass wir in
nordrhein-westfalen einigermaßen gut
bekommen hatte damit zu tun dass wir
eine relativ passabel impfquote im
deutschen vergleich haben so jetzt haben
wir diese 75 prozent rund zweimal
geimpft wir kriegen so zeit jeden tag
wir haben jetzt eine riesige
impfkampagne wählen das wusste und man
kann sich so langsam überall
sehr unkompliziert impfen lassen und
wenn sie so wollen diese schlange stehen
da fragten keiner ob sie eine erste
impfung bekommen oder eine zweite info
da können sie sich auch ganz wie nennt
man das diskriminierungsfrei eine erste
impfung ab wo wir nicht diese aktion
besucher fragt die ärzte immer navi für
erstimpfung habt da heute sie haben auch
welche aber es sind pro tag in
nordrhein-westfalen ich sag mal
10.000 11.000 12.000 erstimpfung die wir
zurzeit noch machen im zuge dieser
poster kampagne nur damit komme ich ja
nicht auf die jetzt angestrebten zahlen
von 90 prozent und deswegen muss man
sagen wenn man meint dass wir ein leben
zurückkehren können wie wär es vor der
pandemie war dann brauchen wir eine
religion durch impfung das heißt sie
sind erlauben uns kurz zu machen ich bin
für eine impfpflicht aber ich sage auch
ganz offen und das ist ja die diskussion
man muss natürlich auch immer die frage
stellen wie gesetze ist sie durch
darüber mach ich mir sehr viele gedanken
ich glaube dass man eine impfpflicht
machen sollte und dass man dann sehr gut
überlegt wie sind denn die sanktionen
für diejenigen die sich nicht impfen
lassen ich würde zum beispiel erst
einmal anfangen mit einem
verpflichtenden
beratungsgespräch dass man mit diesen
menschen ein arzt in ruhe mal redet
welche großen vorteile gibt es sich
impfen zu lassen dass er nicht sofort
mit
sanktionen kommen wurde am ende wird
irgendwie ein ordnungsgeld oder was weiß
ich sein wie auch heute noch an aus hat
gesagt wenn ich mir die zeit nehmen ich
meine praxis kommt ja nicht geimpfte ist
aus anderen gründen kommt mir nicht in
die praxis um sich impfen zu lassen
sondern als ein anderes problem wenn ich
mir die zeit nehme und will ich versuche
medizinisch nach besten wissen und
gewissen aufzuklären
kriege ich es oft hin dass dieser mensch
dann sagte butt dann mache ich es
deswegen glaube ich dass wir wirklich
wie wir das auch in vielen anderen
bereichen können einfach sagen müssen ob
der mensch muss sich mit dieser frage
noch einmal meinte ihn auch wirklich in
der schutzzone
des medizinsystem ist auch mit der
verschwiegenheit schlicht und alles was
dazugehört
einfach damit auseinandersetzen
denn wir brauchen ja diese höhere quote
meine sorge ja das ist jetzt auch nicht
gesagt das plädoyer gegen die
pflichtversicherten pflegt eine
eigentlich nichts sagen weil ja die
leute überzeugen kriegen wir sie auch so
ja aber du musst also man muss sie doch
erstmal in eine solche richtung bringe
sich damit auseinanderzusetzen haben
schon klar das würde ich als
niederschwellig
sanktionsmöglichkeiten wenn ich das
anders ich glaube dass das die einer
meinung sind dass die impfung eine hohe
relevanz hat um aus dieser pandemie
attraktiver war so ganz kurz wird sie
nicht unterbrechen aber weil sie mir das
gleich wieder vorhalten aber ich muss
jetzt sie haben schon an beginn der
sendung und so gesagt ist doch schön
dass wir da diese diskussion haben in
der fdp und so weiter und vivi
basisdemokratisch ist das eigentlich und
wie toll ist das eigentlich das so
gesagt nein das so ist es bei mir
angekommen kommunikation ist immer das
was ankommt und ich dachte nee ich habe
eine andere vorstellung von regieren ich
habe eine andere vorstellung vom führen
politische führung robin alexander uns
doch etwas anderes das ist doch nicht
diskutieren erst mal was zu tode und ich
zitiere an den berühmten kanzler dieser
tage wer bei mir führung bestellt da
kriegt sie auch zitat ende olaf scholz
das ist das gegenteil von führung also
noch mal ohne mich wiederholen zu wollen
es gibt eine diskussion in den
fraktionen nicht nur bei den freien
demokraten nicht über die frage macht
sie impfen sind oder nicht sondern kommt
eine impfpflicht oder nicht ohne jetzt
in details zu gehen das ist diese
diskussion und das diese diskussion ist
nicht profan übrigens mit masern nicht
zu vergleichen weil masern wenn es auch
das ausruhen in der geschichte mit
pocken und kinderlähmung weil das 1 1
für eine einzelne impfung ist hier reden
wir ja möglicherweise von einer
permanenten die wir da bemerkten
wiederholung deswegen ist diese frage zu
beantworten nicht einfach wir haben
leute die sagen impfpflicht auf alle
fälle wir haben welche gesagt auf keinen
fall das ist ein zu starker eingriff in
die freiheit und ich finde
parlamentarier die darüber nicht
diskutieren über so etwas elementares
was in dieser form mit wiederholten
impfung in der bundesrepublik noch nie
vorgekommen ist finde ich deswegen
völlig in ordnung weil die parlament das
parlament ist die exekutive
das ist das parlament ist das was die
entschuldigung ist die legislativen
derzeit ist das was die gesetzlich seite
gesetze die die gesetzgebung macht die
nachher dann wie regierende in den
ministerien umsetzen können wir können
wir lange darüber diskutiert tatsache
ist immer diskutieren ja hunderte das
argument eine frage sei schwierig
deshalb könne es keine regierungsvorlage
geben eine frage sei ethisch relevant
da keiner darauf läuft die argumente
ausgehen auch wenn
sie hier das pre haben
es kommt darauf an wie eine regierung
kommuniziert der kanzler sagt ich bin
persönlich und als abgeordneter für eine
impfpflicht aber nicht als regierung der
vizekanzler ihr herr lindner sagt
durch ein sehr wichtiger wie man das
gefühl ist
der
häuptling
sagt er persönlich trete einer idee
einer impfpflicht jetzt langsam näher
und ihr kubicki hat den ersten antrag
fertig ich habe schon 20 leute zusammen
die auf jeden fall dagegen 33 ist dreht
nicht für eine regierung eine regierung
muss bei einem ins spiel wegen fragen
führung zeigen und schwierige fragen gab
es auch früher adenauer hat auch nicht
gesagt die wiederbewaffnung die
bundeswehr ist eine schwierige frage da
musste jeder mensch zum bund das hat
ethische komplex das müssen wir in
gruppen ab mit der
dieser republik kommen wir auf keinen
grünen zweig wenn die regierung muss
einen vorschlag machen und wenn die ihn
abholen das nicht gefällt müssen sie ihm
dagegen stimmen und dann geht das
parlament los aber dass eine regierung
sein macht mal irgendwie von selbst
findet euch und
alexander sie machen gerade etwas sie
vergleichen etwas was völlig unstatthaft
ist wir haben es mit einem thema zu tun
was jeden in der bundesrepublik berührt
jeden alle 82 millionen menschen die in
diesem land leben das thema
wiederbewaffnung war ein fachliches
thema zur frage außenpolitik
bündnisverteidigung da haben viele leute
sich gar nicht weg dass ein jeder musste
der wehrpflicht ist so ring man muss
das wollen wir ein thema für alle
entschuldigung nein was mit sicherheit
was sie mit dem euro rettungsschirm ist
mit gesichertem euro-rettungsschirms
trifft auch weil das thema überleben
ausgedrückt völlig andere relevanz für
menschen hat als die themen die sie
gerade aufgriffen deswegen finde ich
relevante
thema dürfe nicht von der regierung ein
kanzler dürfe nicht führen wenn ein
thema relevant wäre das ist eine
absolute these
wir reden gerade total aneinander vorbei
und die rechtsfolgen einer
einvernehmlich halb meiner meinung sind
die keinen fall sollte ihnen nicht zu
nahe treten aber das ist jetzt eine
hybris definitiv nicht auch wenn ich
sehr gern die welt lesen nein definitiv
nicht es geht darum dass wir ein mit
einem thema konfrontiert sind was es in
dieser form noch nie gegeben hat in
unserem leben und ich finde es völlig in
ordnung dass ein parlament darüber
diskutiert und eben es dann
entsprechende ab streng menschlich
völlig in ordnung sie man sich zwischen
zuschauer und ein paar mädels überhaupt
diskutiert immer die frage ist ob sich
die regierung vor der parlamentsdebatte
tot stellen darf also keiner stellt sich
tot wir diskutieren doch abgesehen davon
ist zum beispiel regierung musste
ich bitte sie es werden ununterbrochen
gesetze gemacht die er natürlich andere
die natürlich völlig andere relevanz
haben ob wir darüber diskutieren im
fachbereich ob tempo 50 oder 40 über 30
hat doch eine andere qualität als die
frage ob eine impfpflicht für alle
bundesbürger ab 18 zum beispiel kommt
oder nicht waren qualität sollen sie mal
eine völlig andere welt darf ich darf
sie fragen warum warum warum haben sie
da somit mit der ganzen situation weil
sie weil sie auch dieses unbehagen
fühlen also wenn sie die aussage nochmal
sich vergegenwärtigen die wir wollen
gerade eingespielt haben mit was habe
ich mit mit der tatsache dass gerade die
fdp auf genau diesen ticket der der der
freiheit die die nichtdiskriminierung
von ungeimpften und so weiter genau auf
diesem ticket auch diese opposition zur
zur corona politik zu dem pandemie
maßnahmen genau damit sind sie doch sehr
erfolgreich ins in diese regierung
besiegelt und jetzt plötzlich diese 180
grad wende die sagen jetzt sind wir
können uns doch plötzlich eine impfung
das ist dass das was sie was sie gerade
sein argumentieren aber nicht nicht
glücklich können nein also erstens mal
als ich bemühe mich ist zu können
also erstmal wird man gewählt für
mehrere themen mit sicherheit ist das
sind wir keine partei wo es um ein thema
geht das ist das erste das war das
zweite halbjahr wurden 22 in den
wahlkampf bundestagswahlkampf einstiegen
das war genau vor einem jahr hatten wir
pandemisch eine völlig andere situation
dies heute der fall ist dass das ist so
das hat ja alle er hat ja keiner
vorhersehen können und ich persönlich
als freie demokraten über pflichten in
dieser hinsicht zu sprechen ja das finde
ich schwierig okay das finde ich
schwierig da sind wir doch jetzt schon
mal nicht die einzige dennoch mal es gab
genug runden wir erinnern uns an tri ace
und trainer lars und all das was in der
bundestag vor der bundestagswahl war wo
alle anderen also alle kanzlerkandidatin
und die kanzlerkandidaten gefragt worden
und alle haben gesagt sie sind gegen
eine impf das ist kein argument zu
sagen was ich sehr zugetan lassen
das ist lassen sie mich nur die
präsidentin das heißt dass die situation
sich an aufgrund der instanzen die so
radikal gestiegen sind hat unsere
situation verändert und natürlich ist
als freidemokraten als liberaler hat man
ein stör gefühl so wenn man darüber
diskutiert müssen menschen sich impfen
das unbehagen das was ist eine
unpersönliche ich sage es nochmal zum
auch wenn ich weiß was morgen auf meinem
e-mail-account los ist ich persönlich
kann mir eine impfpflicht vorstellen
weil ich den wissenschaftlern und das
was wir ja auch gerade erleben mir
völlig plausibel ist je höher die
impfquote ist desto schneller kommen wir
aus der pandemie heraus dass ich keine
vor dem 26 september vorstellen konnte
das finde ich halt so interessant waren
nein omikron kam war nicht am 4
am 26 september brannte ist eigentlich
schon lichterloh frau berndt und hab ich
das schon abgesehen natürlich sagen wir
ja auch dass sich die impfquote
überhaupt nicht mehr erhöht und es gab
schon längst berechnet
das reicht nicht also insofern aber ich
glaube nach 26 september regiert habe
ich war nur mal
so sagen zur fdp wir haben ja jetzt eine
impfpflicht nämlich die berufs und
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht ja und
da musste die fdp über ihren schatten
springen
vielleicht hätte sie noch etwas
schneller springen können aber dass die
fdp es gemacht hat diesen erstmal
erreichen dass die fdp das gemacht haben
sie haben da intern eher geholfen dass
das ist schon richtig ich habe auch gar
kein problem wenn jemand sagt ich bin
gegen die impfpflicht aber ich bin
wirklich der meinung dass da jetzt was
einreist bei der ampel was wir in der
bundesrepublik noch nicht hatten nämlich
dass in einer wesentlichen frage eine
regierung sagt das ist mir zu heikel in
dem fall ist es tatsächlich in der fdp
fraktion und ich führe nicht und das ist
was ist in der bundesrepublik so noch
nicht ein wenn man sich nur die in
genese dieses infektionsschutzgesetzes
angucken haft ist dass innerhalb
kürzester zeit verändert worden sein
schlafzimmer und 5 x 6 x 6 x